8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
listened in and is live near the las
vegas strip with what they talked about
sally denise on today's kova 19 call
cases are growing and we are seeing
a lot of community spread unfortunately
there is no specific source
when it comes to community spread state
of nevada kova 19 response director
caleb cage says
they are looking at other states to make
sure they don't know what other what
others
are doing to mitigate the spread of the
virus caleb adds they are pushing local
governments to implement more
enforcement and mitigation measures
such as focusing on contact tracing the
state has completed a total of 1 million
344
308 molecular tests since the beginning
of covet 19.
for the most recent seven day period
cases are growing at a rate of 1.2
percent
or 1 267 new cases per day
nevada continues to also see a
significant resurgence in cover 19
hospitalizations and as for the vaccines
news they're hoping to have more
information in the next month or so as
as of right now they don't expect a
distribution in the next couple of days
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now sally thank you we asked on twitter
does news of a vaccine
make you feel more hopeful about the
pandemic coming to an end
57 percent say yes 43 percent
say it is too soon to tell